you snotty little bastard you're on i'd
like to ask for a recess
i'd like to answer the question judge
the court will wait for an answer
if lieutenant kendrick gave an order
that santiago wasn't to be touched
then why did he have to be transferred
colonel lieutenant kendrick ordered the
code red didn't he because that's what
you told lieutenant kendrick to do
i'm jeff when it went bad you cut these
guys loose
inside the phony transfer you adopted
you don't have to answer that question
i'll answer the question
you want answers i think i'm entitled
you want answers i want the truth
you can't handle the truth
son we live in a world that has walls
and those walls have to be guarded by
men with guns
who's gonna do it you you lieutenant
weinberg
i have a greater responsibility than you
can possibly fathom
you weep for santiago and you curse the
marines
you have that luxury you have the luxury
of not knowing what i know
that santiago's death while tragic
probably saved lives and my existence
while grotesque
and incomprehensible to you saves lives
you don't want the truth because deep
down in places you don't talk about at
parties
you want me on that wall you need me
on that wall we use words like honor
code loyalty we use these words as the
backbone of a life spent defending
something
you use them as a punchline i have
neither the time
or the inclination to explain myself to
a man who rises and sleeps
under the blanket of the very freedom
that i provide and then questions the
manner
in which i provide it i would rather you
just said thank you
and went on your way otherwise i suggest
you pick up a weapon
and stand a post either way i don't give
a damn
what you think you are entitled to did
you order the code red
i did the job did you order the code
goddamn right i did